wir sind mittlerweile im donbass
angekommen in konstantinov gar einer
kleinen stadt und der wir damals so kann
man sagen am 23 februar 24 februar
aufgebrochen sind nach kiew auch damals
haben wir von hier geschaltet für
viertel nach acht und gehört ist
vielleicht im hintergrund andauernder
raketenalarm hier im donbass in der
nacht das ist ein bisschen geisterhaft
kann man fast sagen fast alle lichter
aus viele menschen sind von hier längst
geflohen und um uns herum ungefähr 10 15
20 kilometer entfernt da ist die
frontlinie momentan du hörst den
raketenalarm im hintergrund und das
bringt mich auch zu meiner these ich
glaube dass das was deutschland tut was
waffenlieferungen angeht noch nicht
ausreicht wir brauchen noch viel härtere
wirtschaftliche sanktionen und zwar
sofort ich glaube dass der krieg und
dass der druck auf putin nur dann
zunimmt wenn es wirklich ein umfassendes
embargo gibt also wenn es nicht nur ein
öl-embargo gibt sondern wenn es auch ein
gas embargo gibt putin versucht ja
bereits und zu erpressen er versucht zu
drohen er hat polen und bulgarien
bereits angekündigt dass man kein gas
mehr liefern werde weil die beiden
länder nicht in rubel zahlen wollten wie
ich finde sollte europa durchgreifen das
wird hart das wird hart natürlich das
wird wirtschaftskraft und kosten aber am
ende glaube ich braucht es diesen druck
um hier in der ukraine wirklich eine
veränderung herbeizuführen deswegen
plädiere ich dafür öl und gas boykott
sofort wir sollten uns nicht länger von
wladimir putin erpressen lassen paul ich
sehe das ja ganz genau so wie du dass
man da harte sanktionen treffen muss nur
was ich mich frage ist was ist denn dann
die lösung auch für die bürger weil
diejenigen sind ja die sie dass am ende
auch zu spüren bekommen vor allem das
hat er dann auch schon vorhin gesagt die
gering und im mittelständischen
verdiener
wenn das die frage an nicht wahr also
ich denke das ist natürlich ein
sozialausgleich braucht ich glaube dass
deutschland diesen auch leisten kann das
problem wenn ich die bundesregierung
richtig verstehe warum man das sozusagen
argumentiert und da gibt es sehr
unterschiedliche
wirtschaftliche analysen auch was das
ganze am ende bedeuten würde ist dass
man sorge hat dass der industriestandort
deutschland geschwächt würde das ist
sicherlich so die frage ist wie immens
und wenn man sich anschaut was der preis
ist noch einmal hier in diesem moment
wir haben auch gerade wieder schüsse
gehört von weitem dieser ort hier wo ich
gerade stehe das ist ein klares ziel
auch von wladimir putin er will diesen
ganzen donna sich einverleiben bis zum 9
das ist eines der wichtigen daten und
ich glaube dass wir jetzt noch viel mehr
härte brauchen auch überraschen der
härte denn das ist etwas mit dem laden
putin nicht rechnen würde das die
europäische union verein steht und sagt
wir machen den boykott jetzt wir hören
uns nicht länger an wie du unser pressen
willst und natürlich braucht es dann
einen sozialen ausgleich erst sind sie
auch für das umfassende öl- und
gas-embargo was panzer nach
vorgeschlagen hat also ein solches ich
weiß gar nicht wie paul ronzheimer zu
der these kommt dass das dazu führen
würde dass putin dann auf einmal anders
agieren würde eine sehr gewagte these
ich sehe das wahnsinnige dilemma in dem
wir uns befinden deutschland bezieht
weiterhin gas aus der ukraine bezahlt
dass auch pünktlich das ist für
niemanden hier in irgendeiner weise etwa
eine angenehme situation
aber wir müssen natürlich auch wissen
also soweit das kann man glatt putin
schon zutrauen dass das sehr wohl
eingepreist wäre natürlich wenn das
plötzlich ein boykott geben würde das
würde so verheerende auswirkungen haben
in unserem land dass genau das was sein
ziel ist nämlich spalt und gesellschaft
spaltung des westens das würde passieren
und deswegen sage ich da finde ich
richtig dass man damit sensibel umgeht
und dass man vor allen dingen wenn denn
gemeinsam mit europäischen partnern
agiert also und die der letzte punkt ist
die energiefrage das ist eine wo
deutschland das schaffen wird sich
loszulösen von russland aber es gibt
natürlich andere rohstoffe die viel
problematischer sind wo es auch normal
jetzt weitergeht also ich sage mal ganz
nebenbei die gaslieferung gehen im
übrigen durch die ukraine und die
ukraine bekommt durchleitungsgebühren
weiterhin von russland das läuft weiter
und ich sage mal ein glück dass es
weiter läuft manchmal tun wir so also es
ist doch auch bei anderen dingen so als
wenn sein die ukraine wird halt gerade
russland waren schon asche zu legen
keine also und damit kein
missverständnis gibt es ein furchtbarer
für herren der völkerrechtswidrigen
krieg der durch nichts zu rechtfertigen
ist da haben wir eine position am tisch
also null null toleranz 0 wirklich und
er muss schnellstmöglich beendet werden
die frage ist nur wird er denn schneller
beendet wird er schneller beendet wenn
wir wirklich ein gas boykott ein öl
boykott ganz schnell umsetzen würden
oder wie werden die für die verwerfungen
der deutschen industrie in anderen
industrieländern also das muss man
abwägen ich kann das gar nicht
abschließend einschätzen aber egal da
schaue ich dann wirklich auf
bundesregierung und andere die dort
sagen ja wir wollen reduzierung ja ich
kann mir auch vorstellen dass man sagt
wir machen das prozentual und vielleicht
auch schneller ist nicht der punkt aber
das wird dieses problem nicht löst es
ist ähnlich wie mit den
waffenlieferungen ich glaube ich nicht
einmal ganz kurz zu points haben er kann
sich ja nicht er jetzt einschalten aber
weil sie die frage gestellt haben wie er
überhaupt auf diese these kommt das ist
das notwendig wäre genau die frage würde
ich dann gerne mal an ihn aufstellen
gelobt dass er das auch erklären kann
wie er zu der these kommt paul
also ich habe nicht gesagt dass es damit
sofort zu ende wäre ich habe gesagt dass
das massiven druck und überraschenden
druck auf vladimir putin
geben würde und wenn wir uns anschauen
die summen die seit beginn des krieges
überwiesen wurden nach russland die sind
einfach immens und am ende wird
natürlich damit die kriegsmaschinerie
finanziert wenn ich herrn bartsch zuhöre
dann denke ich natürlich auch sehr viel
daran dass die linkspartei in den
vergangenen jahren über russland gesagt
hat über wladimir putin wie viele herr
bartsch nicht selbst aber andere aus
seiner partei mit wladimir putin
ja sehr nett umgegangen sind immer
wieder dafür geworben haben dass man
doch verständnis haben müsste für die
russischen position verständnis auf für
wladimir putin dass er doch recht habe
dass die nato doch näher gekommen ist
und wenn dann jemand aus der linkspartei
die dinge in frage stellt und sagt na ja
aber weiß man denn was dann passiert
dann sag ich nur sie lagen mit allem was
sie über wladimir putin gesagt haben in
den letzten zwei jahrzehnten falsch also
darf ich ausdrücklich widersprechen
wladimir putin haben besucht kann ich
ihnen aufzählen edmund stoiber früher
schon franz josef strauß sigmar gabriel
also kann ich ihn auf ziel da war von
der linken niemand dabei ich habe
wladimir putin noch nie gesehen
allerdings glaube ich dass ich vom land
etwas verstehe weil ich da auch mal drei
jahren aspirant uhr gemacht habe ja ich
habe falsch gelegen das ist wahr dass da
stimme ich ausdrücklich zu nur dass
jetzt zur begründung zu machen deswegen
ist richtig dass man die gaslieferungen
und auch die öllieferungen support
einstellt das wiederum eine sehr gewagte
these weil das eine begründet dass
andere wahrhaftig nicht ich sage ich
sage klar ja in putin haben sich viele
getäuscht ich zähle dazu ich habe das
nicht für möglich gehalten weil in
meinem seminar waren ukraine waren
russen die haben miteinander keine
konflikte gehabt und das habe ich für
nicht möglich angesehen jetzt sehen wir
diesen verheerenden krieg und ich sage
noch mal ich hab das mehrfach gesagt
putin ist ein kriegsverbrecher und was
alles tun dass der krieg beendet wird
aber ich teile die auffassung
ausdrücklich nicht dass ein sofortiges
boykott und nebenbei wir das auch nicht
kommen das bad erst war den krieg
verkürzen würde es könnte sogar zu
gegenteiligen reaktionen führen denn es
ist kein zufall dass sowohl die ukraine
als auch russland als auch deutschland
sich an das bisherige prozedere hält das
ist so und da gibt es gründe für ken
duken die debatte jetzt leider aufgrund
der zeit deswegen würde ich sagen paul
de gehört das schlusswort zu deiner
these und leider konnte die debatte
nicht ganz öffnen weil sie beide sehr
miteinander es war auch gut so es war
sehr spannend so zu einem teil es ist
ein letzter punkt
mein letzter punkt ist das wenn man
nicht für das gas und öl boykott ist
dass man doch dringt argumente und
lösungen auf den tisch bringen sollte
was aus der sicht der linken oder aus
der sicht von anderen parteien dazu
führt dass dieses geräusch im dom bass
und nicht nur das sondern die
bombardierungen die auslöschung von
frauen und kindern die ermordung von
menschen in mario pohl in diesen minuten
die ausgehungert werden dort im
stahlwerk dass das endlich an ändert nur
der eine satz hier paul ronzheimer wenn
ich das wüsste würde ich das sofort
mitteilen aber leider hat im moment
niemand die lösung wir ringen auch im
deutschen bundestag an vielen stellen
genau darum und in einem sind wir uns
glaube ich jedenfalls weitgehend im
deutschen bundestag einig der krieg muss
zu ende sein und wir müssen alles in
diese richtung tun und ich möchte dass
die militärische schlagseite nicht zu
groß wird sondern dass ich zum beispiel
hoffnung setze wenn morgen herr görisch
nach erfährt nachdem er bei putin war
ich wünsche haben als diplomatisch da
muss ich wirklich wirklich wünsche
mir das letzte wort gelten sollte in
dieser debatte ok ok und ich sag ja das
gesagt und wenn sie und wenn sie sagen
dass militärische sollte nicht überhand
gewinnen dann muss ich mich wirklich
fragen wo sie hinschauen denn wenn sie
sehen was russland in diesen minuten wo
wir sprechen in mariupol macht wie die
menschen dort ermordet werden dann tut
putin alles militärische was in seiner
macht steht und diese debatte finde ich
sorry zu sehen nur noch absurd